-It's nice.
It's an annual tradition.
Your seventh time on the show.
-I know.
-It's a big deal.
Although, Chris Hayes just
tonight, that's his tenth time
-Yeah, we just heard
Chris Hayes' tenth.
-Yeah, but he says we're three
games back with two games to go,
so how does he catch the flu
-Here's the thing
that's exciting, though.
I believe you're the most
that have ever -- a pair.
We've never had a pair of people
who's been on --
-It's like we're one.
-We are one.
-We got --
-Dad's bodies. It's like -
-"They played
in the big leagues?
We can all play
in the big leagues!"
-Yeah. Nobody is watching
at home thinking...
-Oh, we don't have a muscle.
-Yeah.
No one's watching this thinking,
"I can't be in the MLB."
-Right? Even you can now!
-You guys, obviously, you have
to make a lot of predictions
And I want to ask what you think
about the post-season.
You, though,
I really want to tip my cap.
You made a call
going into the season
about someone on
the Kansas City Royals.
Explain real quick.
-Real quick.
So, preseason predictions
are in March, spring training,
here we go.
Say something
that you think might happen.
Jorge Soler,
your Kansas City Royals,
will lead the American Leagu
in home runs.
Now, he had 12 career home run
coming into the year.
-Yeah.
-Figured he's...
He's 6'5", he's a beautiful ma
with his shirt off,
nothing like you and I.
And he basically...
-Yeah.
-...has led the league...
-It's interesting that you say
he's a beautiful man
with his shirt off.
-He really is.
-Yeah, and I know
you feel that way.
Let's look at the clip, becaus
I think you say it then, too
-Jorge Soler.
Let me tell you about Jorge.
Beautiful-looking young ma
in uniform.
He puts it all together.
He will lead the American League
in home runs this year.
Hello, Kansas City! We hav
something to root for.
Yep. He's going deep 40 times.
-Well done.
And it's nice to see the clip,
for those who aren't basebal
fans that are like,
"You know what?
He is a beautiful man."
-See, guys?
-What -- You know, what have you
done for me lately?
I think in a lot of sports
that's the case.
Joe Maddon out
as the Cubs manager.
You know, top of the mountai
a couple years ago.
And do you think he will
land somewhere quickly?
Do you think we'll see him
in baseball next year?
-I do.
-Okay.
-He'll be somewhere.
There's no doubt about it.
I think, in Chicago, they will
probably want to have a statue
for him just because
he brought --
you know, finally brought
that championship there.
-101 years. The curse, right
-Yeah.
-You know, I enjoy obviously
talking about your playing days.
Was it with the Red Sox
when you got to be friends
with John Cena?
-Yes, it was with the Red Sox.
-Okay, so, how does a friendship
start with someone like
John Cena?
-Well, this is how it starts
First, I'm a huge
wrestling fan, right?
So, 2008, you know,
the Red Sox, we're rolling along
and we were playing the Rays
and, you know, there's like --
I feel like there's like 5,000
people in the seats.
-There is. There is.
-But every time on the
jumbotron, the wrestlers
would come out --
Hulk Hogan, The Nasty Boys
And then Cena would come out
and he would do this cheer
for the Rays.
I called a buddy of mine at WWE.
I said, "Give me his number.
So I called Cena.
I was like, "Cena, listen.
I know you're
from West Newberry, Mass,
and you're a Sox fan.
I'm so sick and tired of seein
you up on the jumbotron."
So we were busting his chops
So I say, "Hey, let's
get together some time."
So towards the end of the year
Cena was like,
"Hey, let's hook up
at the team hotel.
I'm going to get
a quick workout,
and then I'll meet you
at 11:30 at night."
I'm like, "First off,
who's working out
at 10:00 at night?!"
-John Cena.
-John Cena is, right?
-I think we should show
a picture of you
with your shirt off
and him with his shirt off
And I think everyone
will be able to guess
who worked out at 11:00.
-Exactly. Exactly. He was.
So he showed up. It was,
you know, great to meet him,
and the guy's
a monster of a man.
You know, we had a couple adul
beverages, had a great time.
Jason Bay was with me.
And Tim Wakefield.
-There you go.
-And so, next thing you know
towards the end of the night
I said to John, I said,
"Hey, man, is there any chance
I could chop you one time?
And he was like --
-This is a wrestling move.
-Have you ever seen Ric Flair?
Boom. You can chop the guy
So I thought it was a great idea
at the time, and he's like
"You know, listen,
that sounds like a great idea.
Hit me as hard as you can righ
here right above the heart
But here's the deal.
Soon as you hit me,
I get to chop you back."
I'm like, "That sounds
like a great plan."
-That's great!
-Great plan.
-And it was only two
adult beverages?
-17.
-There might have been mor
than two adult beverages.
So here we go. I line up.
I run back. I crow-hop.
Boom! I hit Cena as hard
as I can in the chest.
He doesn't even move, and I'
like, "Dude, that hurt so bad.
It was like I hit a brick wall
voluntarily.
Next thing you know, he's like
"All right, let me hit you."
So I, like -- I bow up.
Cena's like -- Boom. He hits me.
And I've been hit with 98 by
Randy Johnson right in the ribs.
And I was like, "Randy Johnson
hit me in the ribs again,"
because he hit me so hard,
I went down on the ground.
I thought I was having
a heart attack.
[ Gasping ]
I couldn't even talk.
Then I hear Tim Wakefield say,
"I want one of those."
And I'm like,
"No, you don't. No, you don't.
You do not want one of those."
Next thing I know -- Boom.
Wakefield his Cena.
Bam. Cena hits Wakefield.
Wakefield's right next to me
I'm like, "You're an idiot
I told you.
I told you
you didn't want any of this!
Next day at the yard,
we take off our shirts.
Huge John Cena handprints
on our freaking chest.
-Did he sign it?
-Didn't go away --
Didn't go away for weeks.
-Superstitions.
I love baseball superstitions.
You found one. Was it --
Were you deer hunting?
-Yeah, so, real quick.
Grew up in Los Angeles, right?
So California boy.
Moved to Texas.
Went to school there,
so I've been there 28 years.
But I'm a fake cowboy.
-Yeah.
-So I went hunting
before the year,
and we're sitting
in a deer stand.
You can't talk.
It's 4:45 in the morning.
I'm like, "This sucks."
-Yeah.
-Okay? Then I got my littl
guide, and then the wind blows
He goes,
"The deer can smell you,
so we're going to need
some doe piss, doe urine."
And so next thing you know
I'm like, "What's that?"
And he goes,
"Well, the bucks will come
and if they'll smell you,
they won't come.
But now with this doe urine,
they'll come."
I'm like, "Great."
Well, he didn't tell me
where to spray it.
So I don't know. I'm from
California. I got my boots on.
He starts laughing.
He's like, "Oh, my God!
You don't do it there!
You put it on your boots!"
I'm like,
"Why didn't you tell me?"
I said, "That's funny."
We get down, and, of course,
we don't get any deer.
We get back to the lodge.
We're laughing.
I go, "I'm taking this
opening day."
Opening day is
in a couple weeks.
Montreal. Got it.
Javier Vazquez is pitching
I'm going deep."
I said, "I'm putting it
on my back.
I'm gonna hit a home run
for you guys,
and I'm gonna give you
a shout-out after this."
I went...on the back.
[ Whistling ]
Swung and missed. 0 for 4.
Three strikeouts.
Doe piss in the trash can.
And so, afterwards,
they're like, "Rough game.
I go, "Yeah. I sprayed doe piss.
It didn't work."
-Now, that was --
that was the famous game
where a buck chased you
around the field.
-That was the game.
I was running.
-Sean, we always like to sho
an embarrassing clip to close,
and we showed one
a few years ago of you
on the set of your show.
You're hitting a ball
at one of your co-hosts,
and you would think
that once you did that,
it would never happen again.
So we're going to
show the old one
and then what happened recently.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
So that was the last one.
And here's the recent action
-Boom. All right, perfect.
You're safe.
-Ohh!
-Oh, my God! Are you all right?!
[ Laughter ]
-Sean Casey and Kevin Millar
everybody.